britney spears legal case is she going
after her mom she tunes me out no i
don't you do too say look see
quote she secretly ruined my life that's
from britt's now deleted post where she
claims that while dad jamie started the
conservatorship it was orchestrated
through linspears my mom is the one who
gave him the idea my dad is not smart
enough to ever think of a
conservatorship you even said the fact
that she was even in the hospital was
not something that you
had orchestrated no
it was a shock
you know i mean how did this happen
e.t spoke with lynn in 2008 months after
her daughter was placed on an
involuntary psychiatric hold which led
to the 13-year conservatorship
does she ever talk to you about that
time we don't really talk about that
time she kind of really
shut me out she shut us all out
so why would brittany post about it now
well et's obtained lynn's new court
documents filed monday asking for more
than 600 grand in legal fees from brits
conservatorship meanwhile jamie just
filed for the quote immediate
termination of the conservatorship but
that's actually angering britney's
attorney he wanted to terminate the
entire conservatorship in order to avoid
him being deposed under oath
a hearing is set for next friday but
matthew rosengart wants to force the pop
singer's dad to answer how much he's
received from his daughter's estimated
60 million estate and to provide quote
documents relating to the surveillance
of brittany's telephone and any
recording devices in her home it's one
of the most disgraceful outrageous and
unfathomable things i've heard as a
lawyer